this man goes way back with belichick to
the browns days he's a general manager
for the browns and the raiders and a
long time talent evaluator in this
league
from the athletic and wiesen in vegas
and also he's got his own podcast the gm
shuffle podcast michael lombardi back
here on the show how are you michael
i am doing great rich thank you thanks
for having me please great great to have
you back here on the show hey look
uh you know i i love belichick and uh i
know you do as well
so i asked this question with the
ultimate of respect um is he drunk
do you know if he's drunk michael well i
think you know the one thing about
belichick that you have to understand is
there's a variance in the marketplace
and i think if you just examine
what's happened in the first couple days
of free agency we've seen what we've
been talking about all off season is
that
nobody had cap room and the teams that
have cap room
the char the the jacksonville jaguars
the jets
the patriots even washington to a degree
are spending money
and the other teams are trying to
recreate money
uh yesterday was a huge day in
restructures in the national football
league because teams are trying to get a
little bit involved in free agency
the variance in the market rich is the
patriots were just fortunate to have a
ton of cap room and
yes they're spending a lot of money but
they're getting high quality players
you are they overpay you always over pay
in free agency
but i think the talent base the
durability of the players they're
signing the age of the players that
they're signing and the impact that the
players they're signing
uh can improve their football team
greatly i think the age is where i'd
like to sort of linger with you a little
bit here about the age of the players
it's an important thing
for you for for us to to i guess uh
spotlight
here because otherwise right um
these are the types of deals that the
patriots would just sit back and watch
other teams make and try and win the
league
in the spring and that's that's that's
part of what kind of
is so jarring about this for new england
um so let's get started on it the age of
the players makes it a
different than say any other year or any
other team going to sign these players
well i i think what you want to do is
sign young players who are who can
develop i mean
look at jannu smith who really has just
tipped the surface he's 25 years old
you know so he's not going to be too old
when he gets to his second contract
when he gets to the third contract
hunter henry the same thing
you know uh matt judon very all players
are in their 20
henry anderson in their 20s and so when
you sign players
uh who have durability who have
youth then you can count on them to make
it to the field when you sign older
players
you know sometimes like it would happen
in philadelphia it looks good on paper
and then when it's time to play games
you can't keep the players healthy so
i i think there's a shift but i think
what people have forgotten a little bit
too if you go through patriot
history is there was a time back after
the patriots
lost to the colts in a conference
championship game
they flew to hawaii they were coaching
them then the conference championship
game loser had to coach
the the pro bowl they went to hawaii and
that week probably was the work week
worst week for all patriot coaches
because they're in hawaii
and they're meeting at six o'clock every
morning and they came out of that
meetings
and they signed wes welker they traded
for wes welker and they reshaped their
team
and so this is a little bit like that
they're reshaping their team because
they have to
they have no choice and i know it's not
what we're used to
and i i'm not going to say they're not
spending a lot of money but they have
this luxury
because it's the variance in the market
allows them to do it
michael lombardi can sign players
michael lombardi here on the rich eisen
show from the athletic and
visin in vegas with brent mossberger
here on the rich eisen show okay
so um
we got hunter henry and johnny smith and
kendrick bourne
and nelson aguilera uh i mean
here we go uh and you got damian harris
and sony michelle
and rex burkhead coming back running
with cam newton at the quarterback spot
this is it right like it you you see if
nikhil harry actually can stick
um you know jacoby myers uh
edelman coming back healthy uh did i
just basically name the
the patriots 2021 offense and if so do
you think that this
is a possible division winner with the
bills doing what they're doing or
an afc winner with the chiefs doing what
they're doing
michael well i think i think they
obviously have to come together as a
team and and they have to
and all these players sound great on
paper but they have to come together and
play at a high level i think what you're
going to see is
uh they're going to be in a lot of 12
personnel one back two tight ends
and with their running back and the way
they ran the football last year
which is the only thing they did well
offensively was run the ball
uh it's going to be a challenge for
defensive coordinators to say do we play
nickel against them in their two tight
end sets
and can we match up and nickel with
smith and henry
or do we play our base and try to stop
their run game and then they create
better matchups
with their tight ends against our
safeties and linebackers so
that that is where they're going when
they were really good when gronk and
hernandez were at the top of their game
the patriots could come out in 12
personnel and dictate what they
what you did and they could counter
punch whatever you went you went nickel
they ran the ball you went you went base
they threw the ball and i think that's
what we're going to see
and but it's all going to come together
you know edelman's not healthy yet so i
think that's a long way from him coming
back i think he's got to get his himself
healthy
you know harry's got to prove with the
competition that he can endure
james white probably will sign with
tampa bay if i had my guess
and they've got running backs that i
think they're going to add even they
could even add to the running back group
so
there's it's a work in progress but i do
think if with an off-season
and a pre-season a normal preseason i
think they'll be a competitive team
so last one for you on this and then
we'll move on a little bit
to uh the league writ large um do you
we had albert beer on in in the first
hour of the show and he basically said
similar what you're saying is that the
patriots had to do this but the reason
why they had to do this is because bill
missed on draft picks and this is him
admitting you know i didn't hit on the
tight ends i didn't hit on any of these
wide receivers and i have to do this
sort of thing
what do you say to to that michael
lombardi well i think you know the two
tight ends they drafted last year
or you know they were third and third
round picks so we'll see how they
develop they certainly could be the
third tight ends
in here keane's more of a fullback than
he is actually a true why on the
line i do think that you know anybody
who would say that they they've been
great in the draft i think their talent
level
has dissipated they've been picking low
in the draft as well you know and
and they typically go backwards but when
you look at some of the players that
they currently have on their roster the
sonny michelle
was a good draft pick isaiah winn has to
prove he can stay healthy
and he'll be a good draft pick but i
think their talent level needed to get
increased there's no one going to deny
that
and this is the way to do it and because
once again the market allowed them to do
it
there's no competition for players rich
it's truly a buyer's market
and because of that they're getting you
know you would think you'd get one tight
and you'd be happy they got two
really good tight ends so you know i
think they're taking advantage of the
place
and the season that they had last year
michael lombardi here
on the rich eisen show nick casario
formerly of
new england's front office now in
houston with
one heck of a situation and that
is clearly uh understating what's going
on with desean watson
is his plan really do you think to just
hold on to the situation just hold on as
long as possible
hope that you know we get they get
through the draft season with
watson not saying anything publicly and
upsetting any apple cart
and then hoping that when uh the texans
have mandatory events
and that watson shows up and that if he
doesn't
uh does not hold the management um
to account for forcing him between his
team and his money
and or his his his uh i guess
self-worth and his money between his
principles and his money
and actually start playing football for
the texans for
david culley like nothing ever happened
is that really what the plan is going to
be
well obviously there has to be some form
of resolution
and someone needs to correct the the
reason desean is so upset
now we do know this for a fact that last
august
he stayed awake until two o'clock in the
morning to watch a check that was
written by cal mcnair
that had already had the andre hopkins
traded to the cardinals
uh cash and he was happy to sign an
extension
with a no trade clause in that in that
extension so something has transpired
over the last seven months i don't i'm
not privy to what that is but if i'm
next cesaro
i'm gonna hold tight i'm not gonna allow
i'm not gonna allow
my best quarterback a player that i
built the team around who i gave a lot
of money to
as an organization deter me you know a
lot of players are unhappy i've seen
this over my 35-year career in the nfl
players are unhappy
but players play football they have to
come back and play and the rules
whatever we read about in the in in the
media whatever the spin
that comes from the agents of watson the
rules favor the texans
because once he starts missing games
once you start missing practices and all
that
that signing bonus money has to come
back and you could say well that's not a
way to handle your best player
well i i think that's the way to send a
message to everybody that you're not
going to be bullied into trading
and you've got to take that approach and
you have to take the approach and if he
doesn't show up
he'll pay us back the money it would be
like if we had to replace him in the
game because he was injured
we just have to move on you can't let
the outside
media dictate to what you do rich and
that's not going to be a popular
popular voice to hear for nick but he's
got to do that because if not
he will have problems throughout his
team well i know but he's going to have
pro
look michael i mean you're an old school
guy i'm i've got a lot of the old school
in me but you're also well aware
of the world and right there in houston
you know i know it's a different sport
you're seeing nba players
get what they want uh despite signing
long-term contracts and
the nfl you saw you know obviously j.j
watt get released
and just walk out the door and i
understand he's got more time in houston
and he also was at a different spot of
his career and contract
and what have you but this is a this is
a 21st century
you know and and and if desean watson
doesn't want to play
for the team anymore well because
cassario's got more problems than he
thinks he does have
because if he's not coming back to play
for for the texans
you know uh um and i i i don't know if
the old way of looking at things
is truly gonna work in in 2021
michael well be honest basketball a
different sport and i think that
you know one player in basketball can
change but i also go back to
the greatest coach of all time don
schuller had dan marino
and dan marino went to the went to the
super bowl his second year in the
national football league rich
and then from the time dan marino turned
24 until the time dan marino
turned 29. the miami dolphins with the
greatest coach and one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time didn't make the
playoffs
so football is a team sport it takes
more than just a great quarterback
and so you know we've seen this before
you know in his 12-year career
with the indianapolis colts peyton
manning went to went to three conference
championship games he went to two super
bowls
i think that's a little light for how
talented peyton manning was
i think they they should have gotten
more out of his unique ability
same thing with aaron rodgers you know
one super bowl win
one super bowl appearance i think that's
a little light for how great he is so my
point here is it takes a team
and i think that if the team isn't good
enough around deshaun watson
you know the team's not going to win
which happened last year they're trying
to make the team better
it's a team sport basketball is a very
individualistic
it's only five six seven players uh they
have a better system in terms of how
they control
i think if you're nick cesario you've
got to do because you're not going to be
able to replace him
for what's out there it's the same thing
in seattle how do you replace russell
wilson
how do you get a player back you know
that when the jet when the bears traded
for jay cutler they got jay cutler
and denver got kyle orton in a bunch of
draft picks it really didn't work out
for denver that way
so i think you have to be really careful
if the right deal comes along
but i think teams are a little bit
concerned about trading a boatload of
picks
for one player when that one player
can't couldn't win games for houston
last year it takes more than one players
my point no i and i hear you and i guess
last one to push
uh on this subject is you know
when one team can offer you a 23 year
old quarterback back and two
or sam darnold and i understand that's
not desean watson but when they can
offer you that
as well as a top five pick including in
the case of miami your own number one
overall pick
back at third overall and other
first-round picks over the next couple
years as the jets and the dolphins can
also amass their
their choices to to send isn't that
better than this
hold out alternative for the texans you
can actually get right
you can actually well but the problem
rich is he controls where he wants to go
the rumor is he doesn't want to play in
new york the rumor is he doesn't want to
play in miami he wants to play in denver
and san francisco
so now you're nick cesario and now your
trade options are limited
especially when you know he controls
where he says he wants to go
so say he says i only want to go to san
francisco i only go to san francisco
well now san francisco has all the
leverage in the trade so all the trade
scenarios you go through if he doesn't
want to go the jets he says i'm not
going
so it's fool's gold to get that pick i
can't make that deal happen
a couple minutes that i have left uh bat
uh with you michael lombardi
um we are on a raider nation radio 9 20
a.m
and you're uh working with the great
brent mossberger and v sin and things of
that nature
what do you think of what the raiders
have done so far and what their future
holds in a division where justin herbert
it looks like uh obviously the chargers
have struck gold there
we know the chiefs are the chiefs what
do you think the raiders are doing now
and
and how quickly can they challenge for
this division do you think
well they've got to get much better on
defense rich i mean last year they felt
like
you know that they could improve
defensively but they're not anywhere
near there you know and dockway
is a is an addition to play in the in
the gus bradley system
here's the issue that i have if you
watch the nfl closely last year people
that ran
the pete carroll system of defense the
gus bradley defense
the dan quinn defense these teams that
ran that
down in jacksonville they've struggled
unless you have a dominating defensive
front it's hard to run that san
francisco
was great running that with robert salai
when they had that when they had boso
when they had solomon thomas when they
had
the forest buckner when they had
armstead but when they lost some of
those players it wasn't the same defense
so for the raiders i think the concern i
have is can they play
multiple fronts and coverages on defense
and do they have enough talent
and are they going to have enough money
to get those players because they spent
a lot of money the last few years
to try to improve the team and it hasn't
gotten to them yet
you know they've got a hole at right
tackle they're probably going to wave
the center hudson
they're going to make some other moves
to try to create some situations for
their team but defensively
you know they've got to be able to hit
they don't have the coverage people in
the back end abram has been a
disappointing as a first round pick he
misses way
too many tackles and they don't have the
ability to win up front
to rush the passer in a way to where
when you watch them play tampa bay brady
had all day to throw and i think that's
going to be a real issue for him
does dallas have the horses to run that
defense since now dan quinn is there
because you're hearing the cowboys after
they signed back and
the offense is kind of set as they can
hopefully get some of their offensive
line back healthy
that uh the addition of quinn alone will
help
uh coagulate a little bit more on that
defensive side of the ball for dallas do
you think they've got the horses to run
that
that d i love dan quinn he's an
emotional he's he's one of the best one
of the great guys in the league but
you know one thing defenses try to do to
make quarterbacks uncomfortable is
confuse them
and when you watched atlanta last year
when dan was the head coach
and and and they were running his
defense
after he left they got better on defense
and they changed what they did
i think dan needs to change a little bit
what he's going to do and
it's going to have to be an improvement
with the dallas defensive front because
if you come out and run one front and
one coverage
and the quarterback knows it you're
going to have to have really good
players up front to win so
that's going to be the challenge with
dallas i think dallas knows they've got
to get better up front i mean
lawrence is good you know they've got to
get more players like that
before i let you go give me a good al
davis story what do you got
come on oh there's so many of them rich
you know i mean you know it's
what do you got the best that the well
well like we were sitting in he wanted
to draft a certain player
in the second round and we fought him
for his kid named jordan beck
we ended up picking uh we ended up
picking kirk morrison in the third it
was a big debate whether we were going
to pick them so
when it came time to make our pick in
the third we had an extra third round
pick we said why don't we pick back here
he said oh heck i didn't want him in the
i wanted him in the second i don't want
him in the third
but but that means rich don't ask me to
explain please i can't but that's just
how that life went
she just went there and he didn't say
the word heck did he
right you just like i cleaned that up
way too much
light the flame light the flame uh okay
so everybody can check out your podcast
where all podcasts are gotten the gm
shuffle uh you with odd non-verk correct
and then uh
and you're working with vcen and brent
and the athletic
uh i congrats on all that and let's
let's chat more often
mike thank you rich call anytime
appreciate you guys that's michael
lombardi of the athletic
and vsan and so much more right here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here